can you guess what this is what if i
told you
there's a place where the creatures are
made of glass
or that their lifeforms are invisible to
us but astronauts see them all the time
these invisible glass creatures aren't
aliens on a far away exoplanet
they're diatoms photosynthetic
single-celled algae responsible for
producing oxygen and helping seed clouds
on a planetary scale
and with intricately sculpted geometric
exoskeletons made of
yeah glass you can see them in swirls of
ocean surface colors from space
and when they die their glass houses
sink to the depths of the oceans taking
carbon out of the air
and with them to the grave accounting
for a significant amount of carbon
sequestration in the oceans
we live on an alien planet there is so
much weird life here on earth to study
and
so much of it lives at the edges of our
world
of our sight and of our understanding
one of those edges is
antarctica typically when we think about
antarctica we think of a place that's
barren and lifeless except for a few
penguins
but antarctica should instead be known
as a polar oasis of life
host to countless creatures that are
utterly fascinating
so why haven't we seen them on the
latest nature documentary
well they lurk beneath the snow and ice
virtually invisible to us
they're microbes tiny plants and animals
living embedded
inside of glaciers underneath the sea
ice and swimming in subglacial ponds
and they're no less charismatic than any
of the megafauna that you're used to
seeing
in a nature documentary but
how do you compel people to explore what
they can't see
i recently led a five-week expedition to
antarctica to essentially become
a wildlife filmmaker at the microbial
scale
with 185 pounds of gear i boarded a
military aircraft
and brought microscopes into the field
to film and investigate these
microscopic extremophiles
so that we can become more familiar with
a poorly understood ecosystem that we
live with here on earth
to film these invisible creatures in
action i needed to see where they call
home
i needed to venture under the ice
every year the sea ice nearly doubles
the entire size of antarctica
to get a glimpse below the nine feet
thick ice i climbed down a long metal
tube
inserted into the sea ice to witness a
hidden ecosystem
full of life while being suspended
between the sea floor
and the illuminated ceiling of ice
here's what that looked like from the
outside it was just
absolutely magical some of the critters
i found were delightful things like seed
shrimp and many more beautiful geometric
diatoms
i then went farther afield to camp out
in the dry valleys for a couple of weeks
98 of antarctica is covered with ice
and the dry valleys are the largest area
of antarctica where you can actually see
what the continent itself
looks like underneath all of it i
sampled bacteria at blood falls a
natural phenomenon of a subglacial pond
spurting out iron oxide that was thought
to be utterly lifeless until a little
more than a decade ago
and i hiked up a glacier to drill down
into it
revealing countless hardcore critters
living their best lives
while embedded inside layers of ice
known as crayonite holes they form when
tiny pieces of darkly colored dirt get
blown onto the glacier
and begin to melt down into soupy holes
that then freeze over
preserving hundreds of dirt pucks inside
the glacier like little island universes
each with its own unique ecosystem some
of the critters i found you may
recognize like this adorable tardigrade
i absolutely love them
they're like little gummy bears of claws
also known as a water bear they're
famous for possessing superpowers that
allow them to survive in extreme
conditions
including the vacuum of space but you
don't need to travel to space or even
antarctica to find them
they live in moss all over this planet
from sidewalk cracks to parks
you'll likely walk right by tons of
these invisible animals every day
others may look familiar but be stranger
still like nematodes
not a snake nor an earthworm nematodes
are a creature all their own
they can't regenerate like an earthworm
or crawl like a snake
but they have tiny dagger-like needles
inside their mouths that some of them
use
to spearfish their prey and suck out the
insides
for every single human on this planet
there exist 57 billion nematodes
and some of the critters you may not
recognize at all but live out equally
fascinating lives
such as rotifers with amazing crowns
that turn into roomba-like mouths
ciliates with digestive systems so
transparent that it's almost tmi
and cyanobacteria that look like party
confetti exploded all over a petri dish
a lot of times what we see in popular
media are scanning electron microscope
images of microorganisms looking like
scary monsters
without seeing them move their lives
remain elusive to us
despite them living nearly everywhere we
step outside
what's their daily life like how do they
interact with their environment
if you only ever saw a photo of a
penguin at a zoo
but you never saw one waddle around and
then glide over ice
you wouldn't fully understand penguins
by seeing micro creatures in motion we
gain better insights into the lives of
the otherwise invisible
without documenting the invisible life
in antarctica and our own backyards
we don't understand just how many
creatures we share our world with
and that means we don't yet have the
full picture of our weird and whimsical
home planet
thank you